I love when people like Gary Vee you're
boring you say the same [ __ ] and I jump
right in the mic what do you want me to
make up [ __ ] you got your perspective
[Music]
talk about the content building because
you talk so much about having that real
content behind you
versus just something that's perceived
like the Instagram well look I think
content needs to be real to you like for
me entrepreneurial content comes very
easy I've been selling things since I
was 6 y/o I've ever been like I don't
make content around education you know
so I think where you're going and I want
to make it contextual for the audience
it's like you need to make content that
is your biggest truth the reason I can
the reason I could come here and be like
I don't want you to read me that like
backstage I'm like I don't need to know
the questions like all right improv talk
or when I do it like cuz I only talk
about my truth like the reason my
content works is because it's my truth
it's the same reason my wine content
worked a decade ago the reason my wine
stuff exploded was because I actually
tasted wine and actually told you
actually what I thought about it without
factoring in how it would impact my
business
that was a huge game-changer for me the
day before the day I started Wine
Library TV I thought of it at like 10
o'clock in the morning I sent somebody
to Best Buy to buy a camera and 4 hours
later it was on the internet that's how
I roll right when I told that kid to go
to Best Buy to buy a camera because I
was gonna record a wine video I
completely in my mind at that second
thought I was about to start QVC I just
want you know I just I didn't you hear
this I thought that I would put out a
video every day and I would sell wine in
video form I had no idea how it'd be on
video that video if you go look at
episode 1 of Weimar TV the first time I
ever did something in front of a camera
in my life like I didn't know what would
happen but I knew what my intent was
which was QVC and then three hours later
after we got it set up and figured out
and then today when I filmed it the
second the light went out this is one
I'm probably this is probably stunningly
one of the most important moments of my
professional career that I also don't
think a whole lot about that light went
on and I remember and it's amazing how
your brain works right the light goes on
and I remember thinking all of this like
as I'm like saying welcome to the first
episode you know how you can do things
but another part of your brain is doing
something else
my other part of my brain
saying what if you go to a cocktail
party and somebody puts a glass of wine
in front of you and you taste and they
go what do you think and you say
something different than what you said
on a video and literally that's what
went through my mind and within the
first six minutes while I'm setting up
what I'm even doing there
I switched my thesis from being QVC -
I'm just gonna review wine and whatever
the hell happens happens because I don't
want to make myself vulnerable to the
dateline aha we caught you and it
changed everything the reason that show
exploded is because there was nobody on
earth that I was scared of not an
employee not my dad not my best friend
Brandon when I would pan a wine and we
had 80 cases of it downstairs and the
whole company would freak there was no
confusion that I was doing the
authenticity and I think that's why my
content will always work it's why I'm
willing to say things like I said
earlier that I'm not gonna pander to the
current state of what's accepted if I
just shoot my truth
24/7 and I believe that for you too
everybody thinks and overthinks their
content because you're trying to figure
out what will work versus realizing your
individual truth of the moment is what
will work the reason my sister who now
has decided to not be a stay-at-home mom
and get into real estate the reason
she's getting some traction on Instagram
she's just talking about failures
because she's failing just so [ __ ] but
that doesn't come natural that doesn't
seem like the thing you're trying to do
how do you feel confidence to get
somebody to list your home with them if
you're saying you suck because that
works better than faking it everybody
here can put out a ton of content
nobody is because everybody's
overthinking it because they're
pandering to what works and likes or
will it get shared or who cares about me
it's all insecurities and defense if you
literally made a video every day on
Instagram for one minute that you just
recapped what happened that day in a
minute on a selfie video you would do
well that's why reality TV does well
that's why social does well people want
truth your biggest strength
is that your individual human everybody
just full of [ __ ]
how many people self-esteem is
completely wrapped up into how many
likes they get on a post on Instagram
that's some dangerous [ __ ] so that's
what they're looking for
cuz they're right you'll get more likes
you know and look I mean I think it's
super fast I mean people that over share
their families over it index all the
time
we like that [ __ ] we like the babies and
the dating and the divorce look at our
behaviors of what we consume and that's
great and for people that are
comfortable with that and that's their
truth I'm pumped like if my kids decide
to go that round I'm not gonna judge
them be like no no this do you but do
you like never waver from that cuz the
second you start wavering it doesn't
feel good just gonna wake up me like why
did I do that you know so I would stick
to what it is I love when people like
Gary Vee like I read my comments the
qualitative feedback is incredible right
I love when people like Gary Vee you're
boring you say the same [ __ ] and I jump
right in the mic what do you want me to
make up [ __ ] this is what I believe in
I'm like how about you go do something
with that information that's what I
really want you to do yeah I mean
there's a lot of confusion right now
because it's all new makes sense there's
always confusion when things are new but
I'm very passionate I'm being really
good when when I'm 98 and I'm consuming
my content as a retrospective I want to
be right about everything that is
literally that is literally my ROI that
is what I care about I want to be
historically correct like it's super
important to me like why not that's a
that feels a lot better
I do I really do if that entrepreneur
understands that she or he needs to be
building two businesses at one time to
be happy I liked it better when that
entrepreneur understands that they're
gonna put 80% of their energy into one
and 20 and the other and that the 80s
gonna work like most people's 120 which
allows her him to play with the 20 got
it so that's my belief
please yeah here's what I would say I
believe with you about the 80/20 here's
why the fact that you even asked the
question it's what you need for yourself
the end right like there's some great
say you know there's a great Russian
saying that doesn't translate I mean it
translates to you can't put your butt on
two toilets right and then there's a
great American saying that says if you
have two businesses you have no
businesses right so I get it but that's
for somebody who's more of an operating
more structured entrepreneur then you
have people like me that if I'm not
creating more businesses my main
business won't flourish because I'll die
just running one business if I'm not
doing the wine director consumer
business if I'm you know now Vayner X
has been a real Mitzvah for me now like
oh I could just berth up businesses all
the time and use the disguise of like
well it's the Vayner X business you know
and it's been great I mean like I see
Zack like Vader speakers is so like the
fact that I have a speaking bureau so I
could think when you become self-aware I
realize that I needed those things and
then I realized as I got more mature oh
wait a minute I can build a structure
that allows me to actually get strength
from this versus it being a weakness but
everybody gives advice that is
predicated on themselves which is why I
think I'm always so cautious to do that
which is why like if like I god I love
self-awareness you know you give me like
if you give me somebody who's self-aware
and has self esteem
they're set in perpetuity which is what
I think about when I interact with my
executives or anybody I care about those
two things but yeah I mean it's been
done like to me if it's done once game
over right Jack Dorsey's the sealed
square and Twitter these are public
companies they both own well like if you
really look at it and like you can do it
I mean I do it it's just a pen you're
getting sacrifice by the way you want to
run two companies what you're giving up
is leisure but when people get mad at me
for that I'm like but you don't
understand I don't want to go skiing I
don't want to Ben watch the are Kelly
thing I don't I want to run businesses
it's the most fun for me it's what I've
always done you're talking to somebody
who in the summer as an eight year old
washed cars mowed laws shoveled snow
like my default as a nine year old was
it snows let's go work not let's build a
snowman or go sledding this is my
leisure so don't judge me people over
judging in the other way self-awareness
I know you need to do to you ask the
question thank you I'll take it
you sure can
much better Thank You Brad thank you I
will rock it god I love this guy so much
it's it's Macho Man Randy Savage is
actually the one he passed away he had a
heart attack while he was driving and
died maybe four or five or six years ago
and I'm really bothered about it like
literally he's the one person I wish I
met I loved wrestling when I was a kid I
literally think if you really break down
why I'm such an over-the-top speaker it
is a hundred percent predicated on
wrestling promo videos and Eddie Murphy
is raw like literally like when I watch
it on like old fiber said this app now
I'm doing it out loud nobody would watch
those talks the same way because it's
very clearly influenced by that
[Music]